programming throwdown episode 61 closure with special guest eric norman take it away jason hey everyone um if you're a longtime listener, you may remember we did an episode on Lisp almost three years ago, and we're coming back, and we're covering it in a lot of detail. One of the things, one of the comments that we got, and we did the Lisp episode from a lot of people was, hey, we want to learn more about Lisp, and here's some more details about Lisp and things like that. This is before we really had a strong social network presence, where the only way you could really communicate was by emailing us.
Programming Throwdown 第61期：Clojure，特邀嘉宾 Eric Normand。Jason，请开始吧。嘿，大家好。嗯，如果你是我们的老听众，可能还记得我们大约三年前做过一期关于 Lisp 的节目。现在我们又回来了，而且会非常详细地探讨它。我们在做完那期 Lisp 节目后收到的评论之一，就是很多人说：“嘿，我们想了解更多关于 Lisp 的知识，能不能提供更多细节之类的。”那是在我们还没有强大的社交网络影响力之前，当时唯一能交流的方式就是给我们发电子邮件。
And so we got a lot of email about Lisp. And so we're really happy. Oh, go ahead, Patrick. Yeah, we also briefly did mention Clojure. We did like a collective episode of a bunch of JVM languages. That's right. And so we mentioned Clojure on, we did like a collective episode of a bunch of JVM languages. That's right. And so we mentioned Clojure by name there. And so we have Eric Normand to talk in much more detail about Clojure and kind of really teach all of us a lot of really cool things about Clojure. So Eric, kind of tell us about yourself and what do you do? Hi, my name is Eric Normand.
所以我们收到了很多关于 Lisp 的邮件。我们真的很高兴。哦，请继续，Patrick。是的，我们当时也简要提到了 Clojure。我们做过一期关于多种 JVM 语言的合集节目。没错。我们在那期节目中提到了 Clojure 的名字。所以我们请来了 Eric Normand，让他更详细地谈谈 Clojure，并教我们大家一些关于 Clojure 的非常酷的东西。那么 Eric，请介绍一下你自己，你是做什么的？你好，我叫 Eric Normand。
My current tagline is I help people thrive with functional programming. Nice. I run a site called purelyfunctional.tv where I teach people Clojure. I want to expand it to other functional programming languages. And I basically teach with video and exercises and other online things. Cool. What sort of inspired you to build that site and to teach people Clojure and other functional languages? Well, it's evolved over time. I have always liked teaching well always i i was a teacher
我目前的座右铭是：我帮助人们通过函数式编程获得成功。很好。我经营着一个叫 purelyfunctional.tv 的网站，在那里我教人们 Clojure。我想把它扩展到其他函数式编程语言。我基本上是通过视频、练习和其他在线内容进行教学。酷。是什么启发你建立那个网站并教人们 Clojure 和其他函数式语言的？嗯，这是随着时间演变的。我一直喜欢教学，嗯，一直以来，我曾是一名和平队（Peace Corps）的老师，当时我在教数学。当我回来后，我开始怀念那种感觉，我又开始编程了，嗯，我开始断断续续地制作视频。后来有一次，我在 Kickstarter 上发起了一个众筹，想制作一些 Clojure 视频。那次很成功。从那以后，我就一直在增加更多的视频。
in the peace corps and i was teaching math and when i got back i i kind of started missing it i started programming again and uh i started making uh videos and off and on. And then at some point I did a Kickstarter to get some closure videos made. And that was a success. And just ever since then, I've been adding more and more videos. Cool. Very cool. What is it like running a Kickstarter? I've never actually, I've funded several Kickstarters. I've never Kickstarted anything I mean how do you what was that process like uh so it was not I mean it wasn't that big of a deal um I think the biggest thing was beforehand I talked to my friend who has funded a lot and like kind of saw what worked and what didn't i i hadn't been active on kickstarter at all and so it was like just a lot of discussions with him about like how what should i set my goal
酷。非常酷。在 Kickstarter 上发起众筹是什么感觉？我从来没有，我资助过几个 Kickstarter 项目，但我自己从来没发起过。我是说，那个过程是怎样的？嗯，其实也没什么大不了的。嗯，我想最重要的事情是，在开始之前，我咨询了一位资助过很多项目的朋友，看看什么有效，什么无效。我之前在 Kickstarter 上一点也不活跃，所以我和他讨论了很多关于“我应该把目标定在多少”的问题。
at uh what should my rewards be uh you know that kind of thing and he helped me come up with the uh the structure there um yeah i i would say that my biggest advice for someone who's going to do a kickstarter is take into account the marketing that you're going to do during the campaign so i did mine for 30 days which at that time was the default i don't know what the default is now but at that time it was default to 30 days. And so that's 30 days of you like tweeting and promoting and like just being generally like on edge about whether you're going to make it and stuff. And if I were to do it again, I would probably cut it down to like 10 days or 15 days.
嗯，我的奖励应该是什么，你知道，诸如此类的事情。他帮我构思了那个结构。嗯，是的，我会说，对于任何打算做 Kickstarter 的人，我最大的建议是：要把你在活动期间要做的营销考虑进去。我当时做了 30 天，那是当时的默认设置，我不知道现在默认是多少，但那时默认是 30 天。所以那 30 天里，你得不停地发推特、做推广，而且对于能不能达成目标，你总是处于一种紧张状态。如果让我再做一次，我可能会把它缩短到 10 天或 15 天。
Because most of the backers came in at either the beginning or the end. And so if you just cut out the middle, then I would have had about the same amount. So that makes sense. And one thing that I noticed is it's really, you know, you have to, the audience wants to have faith in, in you, like in you delivering on the kickstarter and so if you're if you're messaging every single day like you know here's what i ate for breakfast today i ate closure flavored cheerios then like people know okay this person means business and and if i if i donate that it's one it's going to work out and two like i'm donating to more than just a set of videos it's like a cause yeah for sure it really helps to have an audience before you start um i think that's the
因为大多数支持者要么在开始时加入，要么在结束时加入。所以如果你砍掉中间的时间，我可能也会得到同样多的支持。这很有道理。我注意到的一点是，你必须让受众对你有信心，相信你能兑现 Kickstarter 的承诺。所以如果你每天都在发消息，比如“我今天早餐吃了什么，我吃了 Clojure 味的麦圈”，那么人们就会知道，这个人是认真的。如果我捐款，第一，它会成功；第二，我捐赠的不仅仅是一套视频，而是一项事业。是的，确实，在开始之前拥有受众真的很有帮助。我认为这是
number one failure reason is is people don't have anybody that who can listen who know, you know, they're shouting into the void. Yeah, that makes sense. So, you know, kind of explain, you know, if you had to sort of explain functional programming to someone who's never heard it before, how do you, you know, how do you sort of describe that? Let's say there's someone who, you know, has taken some courses, they get C, you know, C++ really well, but they've never seen Lisp or Haskell or Clojure or any of these. How would you sort of explain that to them?
失败的第一原因，就是人们没有可以倾听的对象，他们只是在对着虚空呐喊。是的，很有道理。那么，如果你必须向一个从未听说过函数式编程的人解释它，你会怎么描述呢？假设有人上过一些课程，非常精通 C 或 C++，但从未见过 Lisp、Haskell 或 Clojure 等语言。你会怎么向他们解释？
Yeah, so that's a really hard and complicated question because I don't think there is a very agreed-upon definition of functional programming. But functional programming, for sure, comes from lambda calculus. And lambda calculus is a mathematics that uses nothing but functions. And so there's definitely the notion of using functions as your main form of abstraction and functions are higher order that means that they can be passed to other functions as arguments and you can return functions from arguments so functions are values that you can pass around. And languages like C, C++, you can kind of, like let's take C because I know that a bit better. You know, you can pass function pointers around and stuff and people do interesting stuff with that. But they don't have what's called lexical closures.
是的，这是一个非常困难且复杂的问题，因为我认为对于函数式编程并没有一个公认的定义。但函数式编程肯定源于 Lambda 演算。Lambda 演算是一种只使用函数的数学。所以，肯定存在一种将函数作为主要抽象形式的概念，而且函数是高阶的，这意味着它们可以作为参数传递给其他函数，也可以从函数中返回函数，所以函数是可以传递的值。在 C 或 C++ 这样的语言中，你可以，嗯，拿 C 举例，因为我比较了解它。你知道，你可以传递函数指针之类的东西，人们也用它做一些有趣的事情。但它们没有所谓的“词法闭包”（lexical closures）。
It's a technical term. It just means a function that can refer to variables that are defined where the function is defined. So like in JavaScript, if I have a variable defined, let's say variable A equals one, and then I have a function defined right after that, then I can refer to A in the body of the function you can't do that in c so it becomes like you can't so you can't like capture the environment that it was in so you can't really do the functional stuff yep that makes sense so i mean i think one analogy is if you've ever played
这是一个技术术语。它只是意味着一个函数可以引用在定义该函数的地方所定义的变量。比如在 JavaScript 中，如果我定义了一个变量，假设变量 A 等于 1，然后我紧接着定义了一个函数，那么我就可以在函数体中引用 A。你在 C 语言中做不到这一点，所以你无法捕获它所处的环境，因此你无法真正做到函数式编程。是的，这很有道理。所以，我想一个类比是，如果你玩过
world of warcraft um or any of these you know mmos or many games kind of like it you know some of the weapons you know in the beginning you get the wooden sword and like you just hit the rat over and over again but then as you get better and better you get one of these swords that has what's called a proc, which is short for a procedure. So it might be, you know, when you hit somebody, there's a 10% chance of them turning into a chicken or something, right? And so, you know, that process, like that event is sort of tied to that sword. Like you kind of want to assign the turning into a chicken to that weapon and be able to, if you give the weapon to someone else, you want to sort of give that logic to them too, right?
《魔兽世界》或者任何这类大型多人在线游戏或类似游戏，你知道，在游戏开始时，你得到一把木剑，你只是不停地打老鼠。但随着你变得越来越强，你会得到一把带有“触发效果”（proc，即 procedure 的缩写）的剑。所以可能是，当你击中某人时，有 10% 的几率让他们变成一只鸡之类的，对吧？所以，那个过程，那个事件，是与那把剑绑定的。你想要把“变成鸡”这个逻辑分配给那把武器，如果你把武器给别人，你也想把那个逻辑传给他们，对吧？
And so I think, yeah, part of functional programming is this idea that like you can pass these functions around as sort of first-class citizens. Yeah, wow, that's a really great metaphor there. Yeah, I played too much World of Warcraft. Another way to look at it that I've heard about is... so you have... if you're familiar with object- programming you've got objects that have methods so that's data with functions attached well in in a closure in a in a lexical closure like in a functional language you have functions with data attached so those that the the variables that are defined in the scope are the data that you can access from that function. Yeah, that makes sense. So that i mean you know when we covered closure
所以我认为，是的，函数式编程的一部分就是这种理念：你可以把这些函数当作“一等公民”来传递。是的，哇，这真是一个很棒的比喻。是的，我玩《魔兽世界》玩得太多了。我听过的另一种看待它的方式是……如果你熟悉面向对象编程，你有带有方法的对象，也就是附带了函数的数据。而在闭包中，在函数式语言的词法闭包中，你有附带了数据的数据。那些在作用域中定义的变量就是你可以从该函数访问的数据。是的，这很有道理。所以，当我们讨论 Clojure 时
we just very superficially said closure is lisp on the jvm but you know i'm sure it's it's much more than just that um you know kind of how does closure fit into this whole landscape oh uh good question well closure is a lisp for the jM. And Lisp is cool because it's like a family. It's got dialects. And so Clojure is a dialect of Lisp that is made to be hosted on a virtual machine. And JVM is like the first virtual machine that it's hosted on. Oh, I see. Is there something you can't do in Clojure because of that? I mean, because it's a dialect of Lisp, is there some things that aren't there or are there that aren't in regular Lisp? That's a good question.
我们只是非常肤浅地说 Clojure 是运行在 JVM 上的 Lisp，但我肯定它远不止于此。嗯，Clojure 在整个生态系统中处于什么位置？哦，好问题。嗯，Clojure 是运行在 JVM 上的 Lisp。Lisp 很酷，因为它像一个家族，有很多方言。Clojure 就是一种为了在虚拟机上运行而设计的 Lisp 方言。JVM 是它运行的第一个虚拟机。哦，我明白了。因为这个原因，有什么是你在 Clojure 中做不到的吗？我是说，因为它是一种 Lisp 方言，是不是有些东西没有，或者有些东西是普通 Lisp 没有的？这是个好问题。
I mean, it's a different language than say common lisp so there's a lot of stuff that uh comes with common lisp um that is built into the language whereas enclosure because it's designed to be hosted uh it just relies on on what the host can do. So I'll give an example. Common Lisp has this very sophisticated and just a lot of features in the exception mechanism. So when you throw an exception, you can actually do what's called a restart. So you catch this exception and you can fix the problem and then recall it and go right back to where the exception was thrown so if like the file is not found you can be like oh not found well let me make it and then you go right back into where it was right oh cool um
我的意思是，它与 Common Lisp 是不同的语言，所以 Common Lisp 自带了很多内置于语言中的功能，而在 Clojure 中，因为它被设计为托管语言，它只是依赖于宿主能做什么。我举个例子。Common Lisp 在异常机制中有很多非常复杂的功能。当你抛出异常时，你可以执行所谓的“重启”（restart）。你可以捕获这个异常，修复问题，然后重新调用，直接回到抛出异常的地方。所以如果文件没找到，你可以说“哦，没找到，让我创建它”，然后直接回到原来的位置。哦，酷。嗯，
whereas in java and it's just built into the jvm it's not part of the java language it's it's just built into the JVM. It's not part of the Java language. It's part of the virtual machine. The exception gets thrown and like the call stack gets unwound and it's lost. Like you can't go back to where you were. And so Clojure just kind of borrows all of that stuff from the host that it's on. So that includes like Clojure's numbers
而在 Java 中，它是内置于 JVM 的，它不是 Java 语言的一部分。它是虚拟机的一部分。异常被抛出，调用栈被展开，信息就丢失了。你无法回到原来的位置。所以 Clojure 只是从它所在的宿主那里借用了所有这些东西。所以这包括 Clojure 的数字
are just Java numbers. Clojure's strings are just Java strings. Functions in Clojure get compiled into a Java class. So, you know, all this stuff just becomes some concept on the JVM. Gotcha. That makes sense. So, I mean, how are some of these things, like, possible? Like, in Java, you can't have closures, right?
只是 Java 的数字。Clojure 的字符串只是 Java 的字符串。Clojure 中的函数被编译成 Java 类。所以，所有这些东西都变成了 JVM 上的某个概念。明白了。这很有道理。那么，这些东西是怎么实现的呢？比如在 Java 中，你不能有闭包，对吧？
So, I mean, I'm assuming Clojure can't be built in Java. It has to, like, in other words, like the concept of Clojures have to be added in machine code, I guess, to the JVM or something? Well, actually, it's really interesting how it's implemented. So what most of the language is written in java um most of the data structures uh most of like the logic and the compiler it's all in java um the way closures are implemented is like i said it's a there's a class and when you have a new function that you're compiling, it extends that class that function class. Oh, I see. And the
所以我假设 Clojure 不能用 Java 构建。换句话说，闭包的概念必须以机器码的形式添加到 JVM 中，或者类似的东西？嗯，实际上，它的实现方式非常有趣。大部分语言是用 Java 编写的，大多数数据结构、大部分逻辑和编译器都是用 Java 写的。闭包的实现方式是，正如我所说，有一个类，当你编译一个新函数时，它会扩展那个函数类。哦，我明白了。而且
function class has a bunch of methods on it. And each method is a different signature. So it'll have the zero argument method, it'll have the zero argument method, it'll have the one argument method, the two argument method, et cetera. And the class that it compiles to will extend those. Gotcha. And then all of the data in the closure,
函数类有一堆方法。每个方法都有不同的签名。它会有零参数方法、一参数方法、二参数方法等等。它编译成的类会扩展这些方法。明白了。然后闭包中的所有数据，
meaning the variables in scope that it needs to access, get put into the class as member variables. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, that's very clever. It's clever and it's a way to use the function or the method calls semantics of the JVM without having to invent some other mechanism. Right. That makes sense. So for somebody who's maybe really into web development
意味着它需要访问的作用域内的变量，会被放入类中作为成员变量。好的，这很有道理。是的，这非常聪明。这很聪明，这是一种使用 JVM 函数或方法调用语义的方法，而无需发明其他机制。没错。这很有道理。所以对于那些可能非常热衷于 Web 开发
or done a lot of maybe C++ kind of backend work, C++, Java, like why should they learn Clojure? You know, for someone who's already mastered, you know, one or two or several languages, like what, you know, you know, we always talk about this metaphor of the toolbox and how there's not one sort of magic language. It's just the same as there's not one magic wrench that just does everything or not one sort of magic language. It's just the same as there's not one magic wrench that just does everything or not one magic tool that just does everything. That's a wrench and a hammer and a, you know, whatever. And so, you know, if someone wants to, you know, assemble this sort of toolbox of languages, that's sort of comprehensive, you know, what sort of disclosure add to to that toolbox that is a really great question
或者做过很多 C++ 后端工作的人，C++、Java，他们为什么要学习 Clojure？对于那些已经掌握了一两门或多门语言的人，我们总是谈论工具箱的比喻，没有一种所谓的“魔法语言”。就像没有一把能做所有事情的魔法扳手，也没有一种魔法工具能做所有事情。那是扳手、锤子等等。所以，如果有人想组装这个全面的语言工具箱，Clojure 能为这个工具箱增加什么？这是一个非常好的问题，
and it's something that i don't think is is really fully answered i can tell you like there's no general like one answer to to to satisfy that question i'll tell you why I like it and also why people I know like it too. So when it first came out, the big story behind Clojure was that it handled concurrency really well. So the JVM has a lot of java the language has a lot of libraries and stuff for handling concurrency and there's books written about how to do concurrency
而且我认为这个问题还没有得到完全的回答。我不能说有一个通用的答案来满足这个问题。但我可以告诉你为什么我喜欢它，以及我认识的人为什么也喜欢它。当它刚出来时，Clojure 背后的重大卖点是它处理并发的能力非常好。所以 JVM 有很多 Java 语言的库和处理并发的东西，也有关于如何在 JVM 上正确处理并发的书。
right on the jvm yeah it's very problem is yeah it's hard like you have to read this book and then do everything right or you're going to get bugs. And what Rich Hickey, the creator of Clojure, did is he took that book and basically built the language around that. So it works that way. It's very hard to not do it that way. So a lot of the primitives in the language, like, you know, there's all sorts of stuff in Java, like you use the volatile keyword
是的，这很难。问题是，是的，这很难。你必须读那本书，然后把每件事都做对，否则你就会遇到 Bug。而 Clojure 的创建者 Rich Hickey 所做的是，他拿了那本书，基本上围绕它构建了这门语言。所以它就是那样工作的。很难不那样做。所以语言中的许多原语，比如 Java 中有各种各样的东西，比如你使用 volatile 关键字，
and you have to, you make stuff immutable and things like that. Like all of that is just taken care of for you. So it has this really nice story of like concurrency is the default and it works really easily right out of the box um and and that is true and it's really nice and it's weird when i go to another language and i'm like well how do i do this at the same time and like oh well you you can't or you have to do this other completely um like boilerplate system to get something else to run at the same time yeah um yeah that's a huge huge
你必须让东西不可变等等。所有这些都为你处理好了。所以它有一个非常好的故事，即并发是默认的，而且开箱即用，非常容易。而且这是真的，它真的很棒。当我转到另一种语言时，我会觉得很奇怪，我会想“我该怎么同时做这件事”，然后发现“哦，你做不到，或者你必须使用其他完全复杂的样板系统来让其他东西同时运行”。是的，这是一个巨大的问题。
problem i mean you know what typically happens you're building especially if you're building an app for the desktop um you have some kind of ui and you use the person specify some files and then you want to go off and do a bunch of work on those files and it's almost always embarrassingly parallel like very rarely do you need to do like just one like very sequential one thing at a time usually someone gives you kind of a batch of things to do and in most languages like c++ and java this can get kind of quite painful yeah yeah it gets painful because like all the all the pieces are there right like you know well in java to make a thread you just do new thread and you have a thread and like what's the problem well that's only half the answer the other half is now that
我的意思是，你知道通常会发生什么，你正在构建一个应用程序，特别是如果你在构建桌面应用，你有一些 UI，你让用户指定一些文件，然后你想去对这些文件做一堆工作，这几乎总是“尴尬并行”（embarrassingly parallel）的。很少需要一次只做一件非常顺序的事情。通常有人会给你一堆事情要做。在大多数语言（如 C++ 和 Java）中，这可能会变得非常痛苦。是的，确实很痛苦，因为所有的部分都在那里，对吧？比如在 Java 中创建一个线程，你只需要 new Thread，你就有一个线程了，那问题是什么呢？问题是，现在你有了这个线程，你如何把你计算出的信息传回给你要在 UI 上显示它的线程呢？
you've got this thread how do you get information that it's calculating out back into the thread where you're going to display it on the ui right yeah and and it's it's all these like ancillary problems like oh i maybe i need a q okay well you know you're going to construct the thread and the queue and a thing and like you just it just never ends right yeah whereas in in closure it's it's as simple as well i'll just have there's a bunch of different primitives uh one of them's called an atom and an atom is like the simplest kind of shared state it's just one pointer that that you can change and uh you you can have multiple threads accessing this pointer you can read from it or you can write to it and it's uh thread safe and um i mean this goes into like why one of the reasons I really like it is the focus of closure is on the simplicity of separating out all the different problems and solving them independently so that you can compose them back together. is keeps one pointer and make sure that whenever you transition from one state to the next,
是的，所有这些辅助问题，比如“哦，我可能需要一个队列”。好吧，你知道，你要构建线程、队列和东西，它永远没完没了。是的，而在 Clojure 中，它很简单。有各种不同的原语，其中一个叫 Atom。Atom 是最简单的共享状态，它只是一个你可以更改的指针。你可以有多个线程访问这个指针，你可以读取它，也可以写入它，它是线程安全的。我的意思是，这引出了我喜欢它的原因之一：Clojure 的重点在于将所有不同的问题分离开来，并独立解决它们，以便你可以将它们组合在一起。它保持一个指针，并确保当你从一个状态转换到下一个状态时，
you're transitioning from a consistent state to another consistent state, like in a transaction. Gotcha. You can't see it halfway done. And that is what allows multiple threads to read and write to it. I mean, really with very little code, you don't have to deal with locks and stuff like that. It's all handled by the Atom. And this simplicity of sort of, here's the right tool for the job and the language just kind of gets out of your way. I really appreciate that. Yeah, it makes sense.
你是从一个一致的状态转换到另一个一致的状态，就像在事务中一样。明白了。你无法看到它完成了一半的状态。这就是允许多个线程读取和写入它的原因。我的意思是，真的只需要很少的代码，你不需要处理锁之类的东西。一切都由 Atom 处理。这种“这是工作的正确工具，语言只是不碍事”的简洁性，我真的很欣赏。是的，很有道理。
I mean, most of the time you don't need to do these hog wild things where you have three different threads all updating the UI at the same time. I mean, these things were important in the 90s, but now it's like uh if if you have three threads and each one locks the ui updates it and unlocks it computers are fast enough where we don't need that level of control and if you if you uh are willing to sacrifice the level of control you could have a much cleaner language yeah yeah for sure um so so most people want to build i mean there's people like patrick who do crazy robotic stuff homebrew stuff he's got
我的意思是，大多数时候你不需要做那些疯狂的事情，比如三个不同的线程同时更新 UI。这些东西在 90 年代很重要，但现在，如果你有三个线程，每个线程锁定 UI、更新它并解锁它，计算机的速度已经足够快了，我们不需要那种程度的控制。如果你愿意牺牲那种控制水平，你可以拥有一门更简洁的语言。是的，确实。那么，大多数人想构建，我的意思是，像 Patrick 这样的人做一些疯狂的机器人东西，自制东西，他有
you know a drone firing lasers at people who come to his house but but for the rest of us like the other 99 of us we're either building you know a website a desktop app which could include like a server that's serving web pages um or or a mobile app like an iphone app or an android app so can you do you know these three things like any or all of these things in closure how does that kind of work? Yes, yes, for sure. So the easiest one is the web app. Web apps have been done in Java for a long time. There's a thing in Java called servlets, servlet interface and most of the closure web systems are some wrapper that uses that uses the servlet api um there's the actually the closure ecosystem web ecosystem is evolving right now but for a long time the the main system was called ring
你知道，一架无人机向来到他家的人发射激光。但对于我们其他人，99% 的人，我们要么在构建网站、桌面应用（可能包括提供网页的服务器），要么是移动应用（iPhone 或 Android 应用）。那么你能在 Clojure 中做这些事情吗？它是怎么工作的？是的，当然可以。最简单的是 Web 应用。Java 做 Web 应用已经很久了。Java 中有一个东西叫 Servlet，Servlet 接口，大多数 Clojure Web 系统都是使用 Servlet API 的包装器。实际上，Clojure 的 Web 生态系统现在正在演变，但很长一段时间以来，主要的系统叫 Ring。
and it was kind of like rack in uh in ruby and all it would do is it would take the request and turn it into a map and it had a standard format you know the the request method was under a certain key and it was a string and then the um like the port was a different string was a different key and it was a number and the body was you know so you could get this map and then you did whatever you want with it and then you would return a uh in in a you would return a response there's another map in a similar format and then there was a there's three concepts there's the adapter which is the thing that connects to the servlet api whatever API you're using to do the web stuff. So that adapter connects to the API and converts requests into the ring request and then converts the ring response back into an HTTP response.
它有点像 Ruby 中的 Rack。它所做的只是获取请求并将其转换为一个 Map，它有一个标准格式。你知道，请求方法在某个键下，它是一个字符串；端口是另一个字符串，是一个键，它是一个数字；主体是……所以你可以得到这个 Map，然后随心所欲地处理它，然后你会返回一个响应，这是另一种格式相似的 Map。这里有三个概念：适配器（Adapter），它是连接到 Servlet API 的东西，无论你使用什么 API 来做 Web 事情。所以那个适配器连接到 API，并将请求转换为 Ring 请求，然后将 Ring 响应转换回 HTTP 响应。
And then you have your handlers, which are functions from request to response, and then what's called middleware, which transform the request or the response as it passes through. So it actually transforms the handler into a new handler. Yep, that makes sense. So you would basically construct your web app out of these these pieces um and like i said it's evolving like people are learning stuff they want to do asynchronous stuff functions aren't great for doing like async calls um but uh that's that's that's still the main idea is that you got this request map and a response map. Yeah, that makes sense.
然后你有你的处理器（Handlers），它们是从请求到响应的函数；还有所谓的中间件（Middleware），它们在请求或响应通过时对其进行转换。所以它实际上将处理器转换成了一个新的处理器。是的，很有道理。所以你基本上是用这些部分构建你的 Web 应用。而且正如我所说，它在演变，人们在学习，他们想做异步的事情。函数对于做异步调用来说不是很好，但这就是核心思想：你有一个请求 Map 和一个响应 Map。是的，很有道理。
So basically, all of the ideas, if you're used to doing Java, you know, server-side web development, all of those ideas kind of translate almost one-to-one to Clojure. And someone has written adapters so you can kind of work in a completely closure environment and not have to worry about all of those bridges. That's right. And to me, it feels much cleaner. And how do I put this? It's much more direct.
所以基本上，如果你习惯于做 Java 服务器端 Web 开发，所有的想法几乎是一对一地转换到 Clojure。而且有人编写了适配器，所以你可以完全在 Clojure 环境中工作，而不必担心所有这些桥接。没错。对我来说，它感觉更简洁。我该怎么说呢？它更直接。
So in the Servlet API, you get this request object that you, like, query, like, well, what, you know, you call the method, like, get method, right? Yeah. Which gives you the HTTP method and stuff like that. And so you really have to understand this API really well and, and like look up the docs and then when you do the response you have to like do set header and and you're not supposed to call set header after you've like piped in the body you know and like there's all sorts of of like rules for how to use these things. And to me, that's really hard to keep track of. Yeah, totally. And so in Ring, the adapter is supposed to handle that.
在 Servlet API 中，你得到这个请求对象，你查询它，比如“方法是什么”，对吧？是的。它给你 HTTP 方法之类的东西。所以你真的必须非常了解这个 API，查阅文档。当你做响应时，你必须做 setHeader，而且你不应该在管道传输主体之后调用 setHeader，你知道，使用这些东西有很多规则。对我来说，这真的很难跟踪。是的，完全同意。所以在 Ring 中，适配器应该处理这个问题。
So you handle that one time, right? The adapter, once it's well-written and conforms to the API and to the Ring spec, it's done. It's like you can just close that book and say, well, version whatever uh it's done you know you know it's it's like you can just close that book and say well version whatever it's done and um that's the kind of thing i really appreciate with the closure community there's actually libraries that they're like it's done we finished um it's it's not like this continuing thing, like, Oh, well, we're trying to adapt it to this other situation.
所以你只需要处理一次，对吧？适配器一旦写好并符合 API 和 Ring 规范，它就完成了。就像你可以合上那本书说“好吧，版本多少，它完成了”。这就是我非常欣赏 Clojure 社区的地方，有些库它们就是“完成了，我们做完了”。它不像那种持续不断的东西，比如“哦，我们正在尝试把它适配到另一种情况”。
So you don't have this problem and we solved it. Yeah. What about like mobile? If you're building a iPhone app or Android app, can you do that in, in closure? Uh, so there's a couple of options. Um, I don't think that this is being done so much anymore, but because the Clojure runs on the JVM, it can run on the Android JVM, the Dalvik JVM.
所以你没有这个问题，我们解决了它。是的。移动端呢？如果你在构建 iPhone 应用或 Android 应用，你能在 Clojure 中做吗？嗯，有几个选择。嗯，我不认为现在做得那么多了，但因为 Clojure 运行在 JVM 上，它可以在 Android JVM（Dalvik JVM）上运行。
Okay. But I think most of the work now is in React native um there was some stuff with phone gap so we didn't talk about this but closure also compiles to javascript and i talked about it being hosted on the jvm well another host that closure can run on is JavaScript. When it's compiled to JavaScript, it's called ClojureScript. It's basically the same language. I mean, it's whatever you want. It's
好的。但我认为现在大多数工作都在 React Native 中。有一些关于 PhoneGap 的东西。我们没谈到这个，但 Clojure 也编译成 JavaScript。我提到它运行在 JVM 上，嗯，Clojure 可以运行的另一个宿主是 JavaScript。当它被编译成 JavaScript 时，它被称为 ClojureScript。它基本上是同一种语言。我的意思是，随你喜欢。它是
JavaScript, so you can run it on any of the JavaScript VMs. That is super cool. You can run it on Node. You can run it, serve it through a web app and use it, whatever browser they've got, run it. You can do React Native.
JavaScript，所以你可以在任何 JavaScript 虚拟机上运行它。这太酷了。你可以在 Node 上运行它，通过 Web 应用提供服务并使用它，无论他们有什么浏览器，都可以运行。你可以做 React Native。
You can do Electron. I mentioned PhoneGap. People have been doing that for a while. That is quite remarkable. So if you, you know, I mean, JavaScript is very universal. For sure. But if you just, let's say you just hate JavaScript, or you're programming something in a certain paradigm where a functional language would be much better, or at least, you know, Clojure
你可以做 Electron。我提到了 PhoneGap。人们已经做了一段时间了。这非常了不起。所以如果你，我的意思是，JavaScript 非常通用。当然。但如果你只是，假设你讨厌 JavaScript，或者你正在用某种范式编程，其中函数式语言会好得多，或者至少，你知道，Clojure
would be much better, then you can actually write Clojure and it will compile or transpile down to JavaScript. That's pretty cool. That's right. That's right. And you said the word transpile, and that's what it's doing. But a lot of times when people think transpile, they think CoffeeScript. And I have nothing against coffee script but one of coffee scripts like goals was to be just javascript but with better syntax right it's like right you could you could kind of guess what what javascript would be generated yeah i think they even have a it's's two-way. You can actually...
会好得多，那么你实际上可以编写 Clojure，它会编译或转译（transpile）成 JavaScript。这很酷。没错。没错。你用了“转译”这个词，这就是它在做的。但很多时候，当人们想到转译时，他们会想到 CoffeeScript。我对 CoffeeScript 没有意见，但 CoffeeScript 的目标之一就是成为 JavaScript，但语法更好，对吧？你可以猜出生成的 JavaScript 会是什么样。是的，我想他们甚至有一个双向的。你实际上可以……
You can convert it back? Oh, I didn't know that. Or maybe it's, oh, no, sorry, sorry. It's not two-way, but there's a, what's the word? Like there's a JavaScript compiler for CoffeeScript. And so there's actually, on the CoffeeScript website, you can paste CoffeeScript, and it will turn it into JavaScript.
你可以把它转回去？哦，我不知道。或者也许是，哦，不，抱歉，抱歉。它不是双向的，但有一个，那个词怎么说？有一个 CoffeeScript 的 JavaScript 编译器。所以实际上，在 CoffeeScript 网站上，你可以粘贴 CoffeeScript，它会把它变成 JavaScript。
It's just right there on the website. And that's what i use coffee script for for for taking other people's coffee script and converting it i see i see i see um yeah and so that's a really you know that's that's a a valuable thing to do is to like make the the syntax better because javascript can get pretty verbose but closure script is different it is it really feels like a different language oh i see and and by that token when you transpile it you get javascript that's kind of unintelligible because it's it's meant to be it's almost like looking at assembly or something right exactly so it doesn So it doesn't do like asm.js.
它就在网站上。这就是我使用 CoffeeScript 的原因，用来转换别人的 CoffeeScript。我明白了。嗯，是的，所以这确实是一件有价值的事情，让语法更好，因为 JavaScript 可能会变得非常冗长。但 ClojureScript 不同，它真的感觉像一门不同的语言。哦，我明白了。照此推论，当你转译它时，你得到的 JavaScript 有点难以理解，因为它几乎就像看汇编语言一样，对吧？完全正确。所以它不像 asm.js。
Functions compile into, you know, closure functions compile into JavaScript functions. A lot of the, like, you know, if statements and stuff, like you could read them. What gets hairy is that it does a lot, the compiler does some optimizations. So, you know, what looks like a regular function call is actually going to turn into, in JavaScript, a dot call. You know, functions in JavaScript actually have methods, and one of them is.call. And so when you're looking at the compiled code, it's like a little crazy because it doesn't look like you would write JavaScript at all.
函数编译成，你知道，Clojure 函数编译成 JavaScript 函数。很多，比如 if 语句之类的，你可以读懂它们。棘手的是，编译器做了一些优化。所以，看起来像普通函数调用的东西，实际上在 JavaScript 中会变成一个 dot call。你知道，JavaScript 中的函数实际上有方法，其中一个是 .call。所以当你查看编译后的代码时，它有点疯狂，因为它看起来根本不像你会写的 JavaScript。
Yeah, that makes sense. But that's okay because the source mapping is all in there. So when you look at it in your Chrome dev tools, you're looking at the ClojureScript code and you're getting line numbers from your ClojureScript code through the whole stack. Oh, nice. Yeah. So source mapping, and maybe actually it'd be amazing if you could explain it because I have no idea how it works, but basically I've used it for TypeScript. And what it does under the hood, I don't know, hopefully, maybe Eric can
是的，这很有道理。但这没关系，因为源映射（source mapping）都在那里。所以当你在 Chrome 开发工具中查看它时，你看到的是 ClojureScript 代码，并且你通过整个栈获得了 ClojureScript 代码的行号。哦，不错。是的。所以源映射，也许如果能解释一下会很棒，因为我不知道它是怎么工作的，但我基本上在 TypeScript 中用过它。它在底层做了什么，我不知道，希望 Eric 能
educate all of us. But on the surface, you've written in TypeScript, but the person in the browser is still executing JavaScript, the person could be you. And when you get an error, you don't want it to just show you this complete unintelligible JavaScript, you want the error to actually redirect back to your code that you can actually modify. And the source map helps make that happen. Yeah, for sure. That's a great explanation. It's like if you're going to serve up some JavaScript, usually you're going to minify it and maybe uglify it.
教育我们大家。但在表面上，你用 TypeScript 编写，但浏览器中的人仍然在执行 JavaScript，那个人可能是你自己。当你遇到错误时，你不希望它只显示完全无法理解的 JavaScript，你希望错误实际上重定向回你可以修改的代码。源映射有助于实现这一点。是的，当然。这是一个很好的解释。就像如果你要提供一些 JavaScript，通常你会压缩它，也许会混淆它。
And so it's going to be like one long line of javascript and that's going to be impossible to debug it it's going to say line one like bugs on line one exactly exactly so they came up with this system the browser makers came up with this system where you have this other file that's included along with it that gives you the ranges of code in that original file and the line that they correspond to in the original file, in the code that you wrote gotcha um and that works for javascript and css i think and because you know people minify that too yeah and so um it it it's really nice now because they've got it where you can put break points you know you can debug it and step through line by line like what what you think of as a line because it's the code you wrote like you can put a breakpoint there and and walk through line by line even though it is compiled into some crazy javascript that you can't read oh man that's
所以它会是一行很长的 JavaScript，调试它是不可能的，它会说“第 1 行有 Bug”。完全正确。所以他们想出了这个系统，浏览器制造商想出了这个系统，你有一个随之包含的另一个文件，它给你原始文件中代码的范围，以及它们在原始文件中对应的行，也就是你写的代码。明白了。嗯，这适用于 JavaScript 和 CSS，我想，因为你知道人们也会压缩它们。是的，所以现在真的很棒，因为他们做到了你可以设置断点，你知道，你可以调试它并逐行执行，就像你认为的行一样，因为它是你写的代码。你可以设置一个断点，逐行走查，即使它被编译成了一些你读不懂的疯狂 JavaScript。哦，天哪，这
awesome yeah yeah i never actually knew you could do that that. I always had unminified code when I was debugging, but yeah, I never needed to do that. That's cool. Yeah, and that's actually largely thanks to one system that the ClojureScript compiler uses. It's called the Google Clojure compiler, and that's Clojure with an S, Google Clojure. Right.
太棒了。是的，我从来不知道你可以那样做。我在调试时总是使用未压缩的代码，但是的，我从来不需要那样做。这很酷。是的，这实际上很大程度上要归功于 ClojureScript 编译器使用的一个系统。它叫 Google Closure 编译器，那是 Clojure，带一个 S，Google Closure。没错。
So the ClosureScript Compiler is a very simple kind of naive compiler, but it outputs code that the Google Closure Compiler can read. The Google Closure Compiler what gmail is built in and um it does some really aggressive optimizations there's different modes but like when you're gonna release your code like it does all this crazy optimizations on it uh like totally analyzing code paths and like eliminating functions you don't call and things like that yeah Yeah, just to sort of explain, because it's super confusing. So there's a Google Clojure compiler. Yeah, the naming is really terrible. Yeah, it's spelled with an S,
所以 ClosureScript 编译器是一个非常简单、天真的编译器，但它输出的代码是 Google Closure 编译器可以读取的。Google Closure 编译器是 Gmail 构建时使用的，它做了一些非常激进的优化。有不同的模式，但当你准备发布代码时，它会对它进行所有这些疯狂的优化，比如完全分析代码路径，消除你不调用的函数等等。是的，为了解释一下，因为它超级令人困惑。所以有一个 Google Closure 编译器。是的，命名真的很糟糕。是的，它是用 S 拼写的，
and it has nothing to do with Clojure, at least directly. All it does is it takes JavaScript code and it makes it faster and more efficient. Just like you could have a, think of it as like an optimizer, right? You could have, you could compile your code with dash O, dash O zero, which no optimizations, or you can compile your code with dash O three.
它与 Clojure 没有任何关系，至少没有直接关系。它所做的只是获取 JavaScript 代码，并使其更快、更高效。就像你可以有一个，把它想成一个优化器，对吧？你可以用 -O0（无优化）编译你的代码，或者你可以用 -O3 编译你的代码。
And it produces, even though it's the same code, same logic, it produces a totally different binary. And that binary has all sorts of crazy, you know, GCC optimizations, you know, baked into it. And so Clojure is kind of like compiling with dash 0 3, but it's in JavaScript. And so it, JavaScript goes in, JavaScript goes out, but the JavaScript that comes out is, is, is much more, a much more efficient representation of what you originally intended. Um, and, uh, that's different than closure with a J,
它产生，即使是相同的代码、相同的逻辑，它产生一个完全不同的二进制文件。那个二进制文件有各种各样的疯狂 GCC 优化。所以 Clojure 有点像用 -O3 编译，但它是在 JavaScript 中。所以 JavaScript 进去，JavaScript 出来，但出来的 JavaScript 是你最初意图的更高效的表示。嗯，这与带 J 的 Clojure 不同，
which is what we're talking about, but, but you can actually use Clojure script with Clojure to produce, you know, to write in Clojure and produce really fast JavaScript. That's right. That's right. And I mean, it is some really cool technology. It's from Google um what's called splitting module splitting which means like okay so imagine you've got you're developing this web app and like your front page it's going to have some javascript on it but you don't have to be logged in to do it and most people who go to that front page aren't going to log in then there's all the people who log in and they're going to have this like rich web app experience so a ton of javascript and the thing is you don't want to serve that big javascript to just the people who just go to the front page so the idea behind splitting is that the compiler can analyze your code and figure out well the front page uses you know this bit of code
那是我们正在谈论的，但你实际上可以使用 ClojureScript 和 Clojure 来编写 Clojure 并产生非常快的 JavaScript。没错。没错。我的意思是，这确实是一些非常酷的技术。它来自 Google，所谓的“模块拆分”（module splitting），这意味着，想象一下你正在开发这个 Web 应用，你的首页会有一些 JavaScript，但你不必登录就能使用它。大多数去那个首页的人都不会登录。然后是所有登录的人，他们会有这种丰富的 Web 应用体验，所以会有大量的 JavaScript。问题是，你不想把那个大的 JavaScript 提供给只是去首页的人。所以拆分背后的想法是，编译器可以分析你的代码，找出首页使用了哪部分代码，
the back end uses this bit of code and then this bit of code is shared between the two so you can cache that one that's shared between the two and only serve the the you know the the home page code and that shared code to the people who are visiting the front of your site and then then after they log in they can get the rest of the code so it's it's a way to like optimize the experience for you know people who don't need that part of the code cool yeah that makes sense i mean one thing one thing that people might not realize there's an incredible amount of energy spent on making, especially the front page of any site load very quickly. There's statistics that show for every, you know, maybe 10 milliseconds. And of course it depends on different products and different sites,
后端使用了哪部分代码，然后这部分代码是两者共享的，所以你可以缓存那个共享的部分，只提供首页代码和共享代码给访问你网站首页的人。然后他们登录后，他们可以得到剩下的代码。所以这是一种优化体验的方法。酷，是的，很有道理。我的意思是，人们可能没有意识到的一件事是，人们花费了惊人的精力来使任何网站的首页加载得非常快。有统计数据表明，每，你知道，也许 10 毫秒。当然，这取决于不同的产品和不同的网站。
but you know, for every 10 milliseconds that the front page takes to load, you lose, you know, X percent of your customers. And it's like pretty significant. So, yeah, so if Clojure can kind of separate that and speed that up, it's awesome. Yeah, yeah. And that's exactly the reason that people want to do it. It's just that speed of first load, but still provide some JavaScript. And then not having to, like, you know, the recommendations are to do all of that manually. Like, keep two files of JavaScript and, you know,
但你知道，首页加载每延迟 10 毫秒，你就会流失一定比例的客户。这相当严重。所以，如果 Clojure 能把这部分分离开来并加快速度，那就太棒了。没错，这正是人们想要这么做的原因。仅仅是为了首次加载的速度，但同时仍能提供一些 JavaScript。而且不必像人们建议的那样手动完成所有这些工作。比如，维护两个 JavaScript 文件，你知道的，
keep that manually. That's crazy. Yeah, that's way too much work. Yeah, it's too much work. And so we've been talking about all this cool stuff we can do the thing is the development experience in in my opinion is better than the javascript development experience so it's not like it's you know oh you get this great language but then you've you've lost something because you have to have all this tooling and stuff. I recently, so okay, let me give a little history.
手动维护这些。这太疯狂了。是的，工作量太大了。确实工作量太大。我们一直在谈论我们可以做的所有这些很酷的事情，在我看来，开发体验比 JavaScript 开发体验要好，所以并不是说你得到了一门很棒的语言，但因为必须使用所有这些工具和东西而失去了什么。最近，好吧，让我简单介绍一下背景。
About four years ago, I was doing a lot of front-end development, back-end and front-end, but specifically I was working on a JavaScript app. And four years ago, the space wasn't so developed i don't think angular was even out yet backbone was new like it was all all all this stuff and uh i mean we were using cat the unix command to put different javascript files together like that's there was no bower and grunt i don't even know what they are yeah and um so it was very simple times and it worked you know it worked um and then i went into closure script and i was doing the way you do it in closure script and closure script was really new so a lot of it was like. But it was evolving very quickly.
大约四年前，我做了很多前端开发，后端和前端都有，但我专门在做一个 JavaScript 应用。四年前，这个领域还没那么发达，我觉得 Angular 甚至还没出来，Backbone 还是新的，所有这些东西，我们当时还在用 cat 这个 Unix 命令把不同的 JavaScript 文件拼在一起，根本没有 Bower 和 Grunt，我甚至不知道它们是什么。是的，那是一个非常简单的时代，而且它确实有效，你知道，它能用。然后我开始接触 ClojureScript，我按照 ClojureScript 的方式去做，当时 ClojureScript 非常新，所以很多东西就像是……但它发展得非常快。
And then I had to go back to JavaScript for another job, and I was just shocked. I mean, the number of tools you need and libraries and like, oh, you're still using Grunt? You should be using Yank or whatever it's called yarn npm like npm didn't exist when i left javascript before and it's like i i just it is just so crazy how many libraries and tools you need to develop nowadays in javascript and, and it sounds like the Clojure script is easier to work with than mscripten.
后来我为了另一份工作不得不回到 JavaScript，我简直惊呆了。我是说，你需要用到的工具和库的数量，还有，“哦，你还在用 Grunt？你应该用 Yank 或者叫什么 Yarn 之类的，还有 npm”，我离开 JavaScript 之前 npm 还没出现。这太疯狂了，现在开发 JavaScript 需要用到这么多库和工具。听起来 ClojureScript 比 Emscripten 更容易上手。
So if you've ever used that, it's a total nightmare. I don't even know what that is. Oh, mscripten is this thing where it takes C++ code and turns it into JavaScript. It actually goes through LLVM and then goes LLVM to JavaScript and Zynga used it for all of their games
如果你用过那个，那简直是一场噩梦。我甚至不知道那是什么。哦，Emscripten 是一个把 C++ 代码转换成 JavaScript 的东西。它实际上是通过 LLVM，然后从 LLVM 转到 JavaScript，Zynga 把这个用在他们所有的游戏里。
so the idea is if you play Zynga Poker on your phone that's almost all C++ code there's just a little bit of iOS or Android code to handle the drawing and things like that. If you play Zynga poker on, say, like, Facebook.com or, I don't know, even Zynga.com, like, but on the web version,
所以思路是，如果你在手机上玩 Zynga Poker，那几乎全是 C++ 代码，只有一小部分 iOS 或 Android 代码来处理绘图之类的事情。如果你在 Facebook.com 或者我不知道，甚至是 Zynga.com 上玩 Zynga Poker，但在网页版上，
that's also C++ code, the same code, but it's been, you know, translated to JavaScript with Emscripten. And talking to people who've worked at Zynga, it's just a total nightmare. I mean, if you have a bug in the C++ part, you just have to catch it on mobile. Like if there's some bug where if someone gets all four aces, it crashes or something, you just won't catch it on the web. Like it's lost. You just have to catch it on the web like it's it's lost
那也是 C++ 代码，同样的代码，但它是用 Emscripten 翻译成 JavaScript 的。和在 Zynga 工作过的人交流，那简直是一场噩梦。我是说，如果 C++ 部分有 bug，你只能在移动端抓到它。比如如果有人凑齐了四张 A，游戏崩溃了之类的，你在网页端根本抓不到这个 bug。就像它丢失了一样。你只能在网页端抓到它，就像它丢失了一样。
you just have to hope you have that same bug on mobile well i mean i'll tell you like i don't i don't mean to bash on all these languages i love languages they're great but i i recently had to work in c++ um and i don't know c++ so it's totally new to me so i was already dealing with all of the like the novelty of everything but the build system i mean we were just taking like it took me over a week to get it to build on my machine and i could imagine if then okay you finally got it to build and now it's running in in the browser and you don't have any way of no like you know source maps or you know something like that to debug it oh man yeah i mean it's a total nightmare um yeah but you're you're totally right like i mean now things are a
你只能祈祷你在移动端也有同样的 bug。好吧，我是说，我并不是要抨击所有这些语言，我热爱编程语言，它们很棒，但我最近不得不使用 C++，我不懂 C++，所以对我来说完全是新的。我已经在处理所有这些新奇的东西了，但构建系统……我是说，我在我的机器上配置它构建成功花了一周多的时间。我可以想象，如果你终于让它构建成功了，现在它在浏览器里运行，而你没有任何像源映射（source maps）之类的东西来调试它，天哪，是的，那简直是一场噩梦。嗯，是的，但你是完全正确的，现在情况稍微好一点了，
little bit better there's basil um and there's buck's buck, uh, basil's from Google. Buck is from Facebook. They're basically the same thing. Um, but, but even then it's, they're, they're not great. I mean, well, even dependency management in C plus plus is still really bad. Oh yeah. It's a total nightmare. If you want to pull, like, there's really no repository, not that I know of. There's not really a central repository of C++. You know, I don't even know how that would work because you'd have to, you wouldn't be able to keep the binary because it's machine specific, you know.
有 Bazel，还有 Buck。Bazel 是 Google 的，Buck 是 Facebook 的。它们基本是一回事。但即便如此，它们也不是很好。我是说，C++ 中的依赖管理仍然非常糟糕。哦，是的，那是一场噩梦。如果你想引入什么东西，真的没有仓库，至少我不知道有。C++ 并没有一个真正的中央仓库。你知道，我甚至不知道那该怎么运作，因为你无法保留二进制文件，因为它是机器特定的。
Right. Oh, yeah. I mean, I don't even know where to begin with that. I don't, I'm not in that world and I'm glad I'm not. But yeah, it sounds like ClojureScript is better than that, is more mature than that. Oh, yeah, yeah. And, I mean, the thing about JavaScript is it's a huge ecosystem. There's so many people in it.
对。哦，是的，我甚至不知道从哪里开始说起。我不在那个世界里，我很高兴我不在。但听起来 ClojureScript 比那个更好，比那个更成熟。哦，是的。而且，关于 JavaScript 的一点是，它是一个巨大的生态系统。里面有太多人了。
People are dissatisfied with their tools, and they write new tools. But there's so much to keep up with every six months you have to like rewrite your build system because you know it's not using the newest thing and you need a feature from the newest one or um i mean that's why like in my personal my personal website, I use cat. I have a make file and I cat JavaScript together. And JavaScript is kind of like that. You can do that, right? You can just take two bits of JavaScript and smush them together
人们对他们的工具不满意，于是他们编写新工具。但需要跟进的东西太多了，每六个月你就得重写你的构建系统，因为你知道它没用最新的东西，而你需要最新版本里的某个功能。我是说，这就是为什么在我的个人网站上，我使用 cat。我有一个 make 文件，我用 cat 把 JavaScript 拼在一起。JavaScript 有点像那样。你可以那样做，对吧？你可以直接拿两段 JavaScript 把它们拼在一起，
and you have a bigger bit of JavaScript. Yeah. And that's, I just don't, I guess I'm getting older. I just don't want to deal with these cycles of learning a tool and figuring out its JSON config format. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, when I was in high school, or I guess maybe college. Yeah, when I was in college, I got Ubuntu,
你就得到了一段更大的 JavaScript。是的。而且，我猜我老了。我只是不想处理这些学习工具并弄清楚其 JSON 配置格式的循环。是的，绝对。我是说，当我在高中，或者可能是大学的时候。是的，我在大学时，我用了 Gentoo，
not Ubuntu, I got Gentoo. And for people who don't know, it takes about 18 hours to install, or at least at that time, it took about 18 hours to install Gentoo. Now, you don't have to be there for 18 hours, but it's kind of like you get in, you install the bootloader,
不是 Ubuntu，我用了 Gentoo。对于不知道的人来说，安装它大约需要 18 个小时，或者至少在那个时候，安装 Gentoo 大约需要 18 个小时。现在，你不必在那里守着 18 个小时，但就像你进入系统，安装引导加载程序，
you spend about an hour entering all these different commands to install the bootloader. And at the time, that was super cool because you feel like Neo from The Matrix, like some crazy hacker. Yeah, and Windows took a long time to install too. Yeah, but in terms of effort, I mean, Windows definitely took a while to write to disk and all of that.
你花大约一个小时输入所有这些不同的命令来安装引导加载程序。在当时，这超级酷，因为你感觉自己像《黑客帝国》里的尼奥，像个疯狂的黑客。是的，Windows 安装也花很长时间。是的，但就工作量而言，Windows 确实花了一些时间写入磁盘等等。
But this was like you have your bootloader. You'd reboot to the command line, like to just a root prompt. And sometimes you'd do it wrong and you'd reboot and nothing would happen. And that was super, super fun at the time. But as soon as you become a professional and someone says when is this going to be done and you say a week and then instead of taking 18 hours it takes 30 hours to install your os you're kind of in big trouble like yeah it is not fun anymore you know and so yeah you immediately switch to, okay, I need something reliable, you know, that's quick that I could depend on.
但这就像你有你的引导加载程序。你重启进入命令行，就像进入一个 root 提示符。有时你做错了，重启后什么都不会发生。那在当时超级超级有趣。但一旦你成为专业人士，有人问你什么时候能完成，你说一周，然后安装操作系统不是花 18 个小时而是花 30 个小时，你就陷入大麻烦了。就像，是的，这不再有趣了。所以，你立刻转向，好吧，我需要一些可靠的、快速的、我可以依赖的东西。
Yeah, sure. I mean, I remember I used to be like in the 90s sure that X windows would work with it and get all the settings right. There was no auto detect at that time. And then at some point, I would just be like, okay, enough. I need to check my email. I would just use the barest X there was yeah barest x windows the one where you like you you boot into x windows and you have to like right click to get a menu yeah it's just like that or you just get a terminal that horrible grid of like black and white dots
是的，当然。我是说，我记得在 90 年代，我确信 X Windows 能用，并把所有设置都调好。那时没有自动检测。然后有那么一刻，我只会觉得，好吧，够了。我需要查收邮件。我只会使用最基础的 X，是的，最基础的 X Windows，那种你启动进入 X Windows，然后必须右键点击才能获得菜单的系统。是的，就像那样，或者你只是得到一个终端，那种可怕的黑白点网格，
and your cursor is an x exactly exactly and you just have a terminal and i would just type netscape a web browser uh so nice yeah good old days so so let's say someone you know has a website already in javascript and uh it's using you know a bunch of different libraries it's using you know random and using all sorts of different libraries um you know they they rewriting it is totally off the books but now they need to do something which closure is really good at how does that work like is there some type of interoperability layer yeah so because closure and closure scripts were designed to be hosted the interop is just really seamless uh you can call first of all any function you can just call it like like a javascript
你的光标是一个 X，完全正确，你只有一个终端，我只会输入 netscape，一个网页浏览器，哦，太好了。是的，美好的旧时光。所以，假设有人已经有一个 JavaScript 网站，并且它正在使用一堆不同的库，它正在使用随机数，使用各种不同的库。你知道，重写它完全是不可能的，但现在他们需要做一些 Clojure 非常擅长的事情，那该怎么做？有没有某种互操作层？是的，因为 Clojure 和 ClojureScript 被设计为宿主语言，所以互操作非常无缝。你可以调用，首先，任何函数，你可以直接像调用 JavaScript
function you get a javascript function from something you just call it if you get an object like let's say you get a promise, you can just call methods on it just like normal JavaScript. And you can access the properties too. So the hardest part with interop is that you're not dealing with JavaScript arrays anymore. You're going to be dealing with Clojure's immutable data structures.
函数一样调用它。你从某个地方得到一个 JavaScript 函数，你直接调用它。如果你得到一个对象，比如你得到一个 Promise，你可以像普通的 JavaScript 一样调用它的方法。你也可以访问属性。所以互操作最难的部分是你不再处理 JavaScript 数组了。你将要处理的是 Clojure 的不可变数据结构。
Gotcha. So you're going to be dealing with closures, immutable data structures. Gotcha. So you're going to, if you are doing a lot of interop where you're like building up a closure vector of data and then you need to pass it to something that's expecting an array, you're going to have to convert it. And so there's going to be a little performance penalty there every time you convert it. That makes sense, but most people use objects.
明白了。所以你将要处理的是 Clojure 的不可变数据结构。明白了。所以，如果你在做大量的互操作，比如你正在构建一个 Clojure 数据向量，然后你需要把它传递给一个期望数组的东西，你将不得不转换它。所以每次转换时都会有一点性能损失。这说得通，但大多数人使用对象。
There are cases where you need arrays, but that's more rare, I would think. Well, it's the same with objects. If you're using a plain JavaScript object, just like open curly braces, you're going to need to convert from... So Clojure would, in that case, Clojure would use a hash map,
有些情况下你需要数组，但我认为那比较少见。好吧，对象也是一样。如果你使用普通的 JavaScript 对象，就像打开花括号那样，你需要进行转换……所以 Clojure 在那种情况下，Clojure 会使用哈希映射，
a Clojure hash map. So you would need to convert it to a JavaScript object. Okay, that makes sense. Which basically requires walking down the hash map and converting everything into something that javascript would would use yeah that makes sense cool um so what about i mean you know we have sort of a faction of the audience um a faction is is faction like a i feel like faction is a connotatively positive word but now i'm starting to doubt myself we have a portion yeah we have we have a portion we have a section
一个 Clojure 哈希映射。所以你需要把它转换成 JavaScript 对象。好的，这说得通。这基本上需要遍历哈希映射并将所有内容转换为 JavaScript 可以使用的东西。是的，这说得通。酷。那么，我是说，我们有一部分听众，“派系”（faction）这个词，我觉得“派系”是一个带有褒义的词，但现在我开始怀疑自己了。我们有一部分，是的，我们有一部分，我们有一部分
of the audience that's just really into the career side you know it's it's people who want to get into the industry um and and so they're you know right now they're really wondering what's the job market or even if they're doing freelance they want to do freelance work, they're wondering how would this affect my freelance work does this give me some if I'm given the freedom to use any language
听众真的对职业方面很感兴趣，你知道，是那些想进入这个行业的人。所以他们现在真的很想知道就业市场是什么样的，或者即使他们做自由职业，他们也想做自由职业，他们想知道这会如何影响我的自由职业。如果我被赋予使用任何语言的自由，这会提高我的生产力吗？那么，在商业方面，Clojure 目前有多丰富？这是一个非常好的问题。所以我将分部分来回答。现在有很多 Clojure 的工作机会，我是说，它不是 JavaScript，因为你知道，基本上每家公司都有 JavaScript。所以如果他们要规定你使用什么语言，要求 ClojureScript 的公司要少得多，但它们确实存在，它们绝对存在，
does this boost my productivity? And so what is sort of the, you know, on the business end of it, how rich is sort of Clojure right now? That is a really good question. So I'm going to take it in parts. There's a lot of Clo of closure jobs out there right now i mean it's not it's not javascript right because you know basically every company has javascript right um and so if they're going to dictate what language you're going to use there's there's much fewer companies that are asking for closure script um but they're out there they're definitely out
而且它们正在寻找人才。我确实必须说几件事，因为这是一个较小的群体，所以更容易进入。而且我相信，我该怎么说呢？如果你有 JavaScript 开发人员质量的正态曲线，你有 ClojureScript 开发人员质量的正态曲线，显然 ClojureScript 的正态曲线是 JavaScript 曲线旁边的一个更小的、微小的东西，但平均水平更高。是的，因为 Clojure 和 ClojureScript 可能不是他们的第一语言，而在 JavaScript 中，JavaScript 更有可能是他们的第一语言。所以即使你只是认为拥有两种语言的人比拥有一种语言的人更好，
there and they're looking for people um i i do have to say a couple of things because it's a smaller um smaller group it is easier to to get into um and it is i believe um how do i put this if if you have the javascript normal curve of like quality of developer and you have the closure script normal curve of quality of developer obviously the closure script normal curve is like a smaller like tiny little thing next to the javascript curve but the average is higher yeah because closure and closure script are probably not their first language whereas in javascript it's it's more much more likely that javascript is their first language so even if you just think someone with two languages is better than one,
你在 Clojure 和 ClojureScript 这边就有这个优势。这说得通。我认为加入一个较小的社区有很多好处，尤其是当你刚开始学习的时候。我是说，有很多资源。有非常热爱它的人。而且你不会完全被淹没。我是说，如果你把 JavaScript 作为第一语言学习，并且以一种专业的方式学习它，你就像 Eric 提到的那样，完全被所有不同的工具、所有不同的库淹没了。听起来 ClojureScript，你知道，有一个较小的社区，
you've got that going for the Clojure and ClojureScript side. That makes sense. I think there's a lot to be said for joining a smaller community, especially when you're just learning. I mean, there's a lot of resources. There's people who are very passionate about it. And you're not just completely swamped. I mean, if you were to learn JavaScript as your first language and learn it in sort of a professional sense, you're just completely swamped with, as Eric mentioned, just all the different tools, all the different libraries. And it sounds like ClojureScript, you know, with a smaller community,
你可以真正深入研究并获得很好的理解。是的，当然。而且，我是说，每个人，或者不是每个人，我们很多人都听说过 JavaScript 实际上是在 10 天内设计出来的，这有点夸张，但离事实不远。而 Clojure 和 ClojureScript 有着更丰富的历史，投入了大量的设计工作。所以当你用它编程时，能明显感觉到事情比在 JavaScript 中考虑得更周全。是的，而且我认为事情开始朝着
you can really kind of dive deep and get a good understanding. Yeah, for sure. And it is a, I mean, everyone, or not everyone, many of us have heard this story that JavaScript was actually designed in 10 days, which is kind of an exaggeration, but it's not far from the truth. Whereas Clojure and ClojureScript have a much richer history and a lot of design work went into it. So it's palpable when you're programming in it that things were thought out much more than in JavaScript. Yeah, and I think things are starting to trend
功能更全的语言方向发展。我是说，如果你看看 Haskell 和 Scala，例如，它们有类型推断，现在的浏览器更复杂了，所以你可以看到推断出的类型。因此，浏览器和工具变得越来越复杂，加上项目本身变得越来越复杂，
in the direction of more fully featured languages. I mean, if you look at Haskell and Scala, for example, they have type inferencing, and the browsers now are more sophisticated, so you can see the inferred type. And so a combination of the browser and the tooling getting more sophisticated, and also the projects just becoming more complex,
这在某种程度上决定了需要更具原则性的语言。所以这就是为什么 JavaScript 有这么多替代品的原因之一，比如你可以用这么多不同的方式编写 JavaScript，因为当项目变得非常庞大和复杂时，人们根本无法仅靠原生 JavaScript 维持。所以是的，我认为 ClojureScript 对人们来说是一个很好的入门语言。是的，我刚做了一个研讨会，我们用了 ClojureScript，而且他们很多人都是第一次编程。进展很顺利。我们需要安装的东西数量，
it sort of dictates languages that are more principled. And so that's one of the reasons why there's just so many alternatives to JavaScript, like so many different ways you can write JavaScript because people just can't get by with native javascript when the project gets very large and complicated um and so yeah i think i think closure script would be a great first thing for people to learn yeah i mean i just did a workshop and we did closure script um it's and a lot of them were first-time programmers. And it went well. The number of things we had to install,
我想我们只需要在他们的电脑上安装两个程序。我们需要在上面安装 JVM，因为 ClojureScript 编译器确实运行在 JVM 上。它是用 Clojure 编写的。然后我们需要安装 Leiningen，这是 Clojure 的项目管理工具。有了这两样东西，你就完成了。甚至编辑器，这真的很疯狂，但有一个叫 Nightlight 的编辑器，它只是 Leiningen 的一个插件，所以它运行起来就像你输入 `lein nightlight`，然后你得到一个编辑器，你知道，你打开浏览器到一个特定的 URL，你就拥有了一个
I think we had to install two programs on their computer. We had to get the JVM on there because the Clojure script compiler does run on the JVM. It's written in Clojure. And then we had to get L lining in which is the closure project management tool and with those two things like you're done like that even the editor this is really crazy but there's an editor called nightlight that is just a plugin for lining in so it runs like you just type line nightlight and you get an editor that you know you open your browser and to a certain url and you've got an
编辑器来编辑该项目中的代码。哦，不错，不错。而且你还有一个带有另一个插件的实时重载功能。所以你正在输入，你可以看到浏览器中的变化。你可以看到它的效果。所以这是一种令人惊叹的体验，有人可以在终端输入几个命令，就能获得这种开发体验。是的，非常酷。是的。
editor editing the code in that project oh nice, nice. And you've got live reloading with another plugin. So you're typing and you can see the change in your browser. You can see the effect of that. And so it's just an amazing experience that someone can type a couple commands at the terminal and get this development experience going. Yeah, very cool. Yeah.
现在，你提到了自由职业。所以那一点，我认为可能是你最能获得回报的地方。比如，如果你真的可以选择任何你想要的语言，我认为在很多自由职业情况下都是这样。我是说，以我的经验，它比 JavaScript 好得多。如果我要做自由职业，我毫无疑问会选择 Clojure 和 ClojureScript。你绝对可以做一些非常厉害的套利。我是说，如果有一个项目，ClojureScript 会让它变得高效得多，
Now, you mentioned freelancing. So that one, I think, is probably where you're going to see the most bang for your buck. Like, if you really can choose whatever language you want um which i think is the case in a lot of freelance situations i mean it is such a it's so much better than than javascript in in my experience like if i was going to do freelance i would do closure and closure script no doubt um you can definitely do some pretty sick arbitrage. I mean, if there's a project where ClojureScript would make this so much more efficient,
但对方期望你用 JavaScript 编写，你实际上可以以两倍的速度完成它。是的，完全正确。而且我，我一直在等待，比如已经等了几年了，但对于 React，我们听说 React 是函数式的，对吧？好吧，当你拥有一门函数式语言和一个函数式框架时，它们配合得非常好。ClojureScript 中的 React 封装，实际上有几个很受欢迎的，
but the person expects you to be writing this in JavaScript, you could actually do it twice as fast. Yeah, exactly. And I, I'm kind of, I've been waiting for a little bit, like a couple years now, but with React, so we've heard that React is functional, right? Well, when you have a functional language and a functional framework, it just works so well together. The React wrappers in ClojureScript, there's actually several that are popular,
但 React 封装让它变得非常好。比如一个组件只是一个单一的函数。我是说，如果你想的话，你可以做所有的生命周期工作，但大多数时候你不需要它。你把你的状态保存在一个 atom 中。而且基于状态 UI 如何变化，以及向状态添加东西、从状态移除东西、改变 UI，这一切都非常清晰。总之，这是一种非常好的开发体验，
but the React wrappers make it so nice. Like a component is just a single function. And I mean, you can do all the lifecycle stuff if you want, but mostly you don't need it. And you keep your state in an atom. And it's just so clear how your UI is changing based on the state and adding stuff to the state, removing stuff from the state, changing the UI. Anyway, it is such a nice development experience
我一直期待有人能，比如，在黑客马拉松中横扫全场，你知道，只是，在 48 小时内做一些令人惊叹的事情，没人会相信这是可能的，因为他们使用的是 ClojureScript。我一直在等待它的发生，但我还没看到。所以只是时间问题。
that I've been expecting someone to, like, sweep a hackathon, you know, just, like, do something amazing in 48 hours that no one else would believe was even possible because they were using closure script. I've been waiting for it to happen, but I haven't seen it yet. So only a matter of time.
是的。是的。也许，也许是因为像，像 ClojureScript。所以，我，我，我觉得我没有给予它足够的评价。
Yeah. Yeah. Maybe, maybe because like, like the closure script. So I, I, I don't think I've done it enough justice.
所以不仅开发体验很棒，你有实时重载，当我提到实时重载时，它并不意味着它只是自动刷新浏览器。它的意思是你的状态，你的应用状态，仍然在那里，但 UI，比如你改变了你的 UI 代码。所以你可以点击几下，你知道，
So not only is the development experience great where you have live reloading, and when I say live reloading, it doesn't mean it just refreshes the browser automatically. What it means is your state, your app state, is still there, but the UI, like you've changed your UI code. And so you could be like a few clicks in, you know,
就像你在测试你的应用。是的，你有一个电子邮件应用，邮件写了一半。对。然后你觉得，噢，那个组件看起来不太对，或者让我给这个工具栏添加加粗功能，你知道，随便什么。你只需要添加代码来给工具栏添加加粗功能，砰，组件就变了，而邮件文本还在那里。这太棒了。是的，当我们三年前解释函数式语言时，
like you're testing out your app. Yeah, you have an email app and the email is half written. Right. And then you're like, ooh, that component doesn't really look right or let me add bold to this toolbar, you know, whatever. And you just add the code to add bold to the toolbar and boom, the component just changes and the email text is still in there. That's awesome. Yeah, when we explained functional languages three years ago now,
你知道，我们告诉人们，很多人说，噢，我从来没做过函数式编程。我们告诉人们的是，实际上，是的，你做过，而且可能你的父母也做过。它叫 Excel，对吧？你知道，当你使用 Excel 时，你输入一个公式，然后你粘贴一些数据，然后就像魔法一样，你知道，当你使用 Excel 时，你输入一个公式，然后你粘贴一些数据，就像魔法一样，你知道，当你改变公式时，电子表格就在变化。如果它感觉如此生动和神奇，我是说，听起来用，你知道，ClojureScript，你得到了同样的感觉，但是在 Web 开发中。是的，当然。当然。
you know, we told people, a lot of people say, oh, I've never done functional programming. And what we've told people is actually, yes, you have, and probably your parents have too. It's called Excel, right? And you know, when you're using Excel, and you type a formula, and then you paste some data, and just kind of magically, you know, and as you're using Excel and you type a formula and then you, you paste some data and just kind of magically, you know, and as you're changing the formula, the spreadsheet is just changing. And if it feels so kind of alive and magical, I mean, it sounds like with, you know, a closure script, you get that same feeling, but with web development. Yeah, for sure. For sure.
然后你回到必须重新加载，然后像点击几下打开你正在查看的东西，以确保你做得对。然后，噢，我没做对，或者我想再稍微改变一下样式，你必须改变代码，然后重新加载。我再也没有耐心做那个了。我被宠坏了。所以如果有人想学习 Clojure，最好的入门方式是什么？哦，好问题。有很多书，但我实际上要借此机会宣传一下我的东西。所以我有了 purelyfunctional.tv，那里有，哦，哇，
And you go back to where you have to reload and then like click through a few things to open the thing back up that you were looking at to make sure that you did it right. And then, oh, I didn't do it right or I want to change the styling a little bit more and you have to change the code and then reload. And like I have no patience for that anymore. I've been spoiled so so if someone wants to learn closure what's sort of the best you know way that they can get started oh good question uh there's a lot of books um but i'm actually going to take this as a as a cue to plug my stuff um so i've got uh purely functional.tv there's um oh wow
150 多个视频，哦，哇，长度不等。而且它们大多数都在付费墙后面，但有一些东西是免费提供的，如果你想测试一下看看你是否喜欢它。有一个叫“Clojure 入门”，那不是 ClojureScript，它是常规的 Clojure，但它是相同的语法、相同的数据结构、相同的核心库。所以它会帮助你上路。而且，我设置了一个页面，purelyfunctional.tv/throwdown。我会给你一个不错的优惠券代码，用于订阅折扣。哦，非常酷。
150 something videos on there oh wow of varying lengths um and most of them are like behind a paywall but there are some things that are um that are available for free if you want to just test them out and see if you like it um there's one called intro to closure and that's not closure script it's it's regular closure but it's the same syntax, same data structures, same core library. So it'll help you on your way. And also, I've got a page set up, purelyfunctional.tv slash throwdown. And I'll give you a nice coupon code for a discount on a subscription. Oh, very cool.
所以是的，回顾一下，如果你去，嗯，第一部分是什么？purelyfunctional.tv，purelyfunctional.tv/throwdown，我假设全是小写，没有连字符之类的，对吧？是的。所以，purelyfunctional.tv/throwdown，如果你访问那个 URL，你实际上可以获得网站上一些高级内容的折扣。是的，是的。而且，你知道，和我联系。我的电子邮件是 eric@listcast.com。我喜欢回答关于 Clojure 的电子邮件。你有任何问题，那也会很棒。
So yeah, just to recap, if you go to um what was the first part purely functional.tv purely functional.tv slash throwdown i'm assuming all one word no hyphens or anything right yep so so uh purely functional.tv slash throwdown if you go to that url um you actually get a discount for discount for some of the premium content on the site. Yeah, yeah. And, you know, get in touch with me. My email is eric at listcast.com. I love answering email about Clojure. Any questions you have, that would be great too.
酷。太棒了。是的，我是说，我绝对会去看看。这超级酷。我实际上不知道 Clojure 可以与 React 和 React Native 一起使用。我一直在努力学习 React 和 React Native。我是说，我最终确实学会了它们，
Cool. Awesome. Yeah, I mean, I'm definitely going to check this out. This is super cool. I had no idea, actually, that Clojure could be used with React and React Native. I've struggled trying to learn React and React Native. I mean, I did learn them eventually,
但它并不直观。所以我打算试一试，看看它是否感觉更自然。这很奇怪。我觉得好像有些事情，试图举个好例子。我认为实际上 JavaScript 就是其中之一。比如 JavaScript 对我来说感觉很自然，因为当我做它的时候，我只是受到启发继续做下去。还有其他事情，比如 Scala 是一个很好的例子，我写了一些 Scala，我只是想少写点 Scala。我为了工作不得不做，所以我硬着头皮完成了。
but it was not intuitive. And so I'm going to give this a shot and see if it feels more natural. It's weird. I feel as if there are some things like, trying to give a good example. I think actually JavaScript is one of them. Like JavaScript felt natural to me insofar as when I was doing it, I was just inspired to keep doing it. There are other things, like Scala is a good example, where I write some Scala and I just want to write less Scala. I had to do it for a job, so I kind of powered through it.
我觉得 React Native 是这些事情之一，我做得越多，我就越不想做。我想我会尝试 Clojure，我想是 ClojureScript，看看它是否感觉更自然。好吧，我实际上有同样的经历。我为一个客户使用 JavaScript 和 React Native，而且，我是说，有太多东西要学了，这是真实的情况。就像我想完成一些事情，但
And I feel React Native is one of these things where the more I did it, the less I wanted to do it. And I'm going to try with Clojure, I guess with Clojure Script, and see if it feels more natural. Well, I actually had the same experience. I was using JavaScript in React Native for a client, and it was, I mean, there was just so much to learn that was the real thing it's like i want to get something done but
你知道，有所有这些生命周期的事情，而且，很多工具都有点奇怪，然后还有，所有的样式和必须学习的新组件。是的，而且，最重要的一点，我不认为我们解决了，我想没人解决过这个问题，路由，我不喜欢，我没做太多移动开发，显然路由非常重要，我只是不明白。是的，一样，但，你知道，它与跟踪后退按钮之类的事情有关，可以从右侧滑入，从底部滑入，就像你希望当你点击后退按钮时，它记得去哪里。总之，显然这是一个难题，而且，我当时想，好吧，我在 React Native 中找到了方向，那很酷，所以我尝试了
you know there's all this life cycle things and um a lot of the the tooling was was kind of weird and then there was uh all the styling and the the new components that you had to learn yeah um and then the the biggest thing of all which i don't think we ever solved i think no one has solved this yet the routing which i don't like i don't do much mobile development apparently routing is like really important and i just don't get it um yeah same but but uh you know it has to do with like keeping track of the back button and stuff can slide in from the right and slide in from the bottom and like you want it when you hit the back button like you want it to remember the to go to um anyway apparently that's a hard problem and um i then was like well i got my i got my bearings in the react native and that and that was cool and so then i tried it with
ClojureScript，它真的太有趣了。现在，我没有做一个带有许多屏幕之类的复杂应用，但它实际上感觉像，哇，我现在可以制作所有那些我以为应该很容易做的应用了。你知道，比如我想做一个小费计算器之类的。是的，是的，完全正确。比如我想跟踪我的跑步，所以我想要跟踪我的跑步，我使用 RunKeeper，但它对于我需要的东西来说太复杂了。我只是想要一些东西，比如我点击一个按钮，我就开始跑步。我做到了，而且它太好了。所以我实际上正在制作一个关于我制作的那个应用的课程。
closure script and it was just it was just so fun now i didn't make like a complicated app with a lot of screens and stuff but it actually felt like wow i can now make all those little apps that i thought should be easy to do you know like i wanted to make a like a tip calculator or something yeah yeah exactly like i want to track my i run so i want to track my runs and i I use RunKeeper, but it's overly complicated for what I need. I just want something like I click a button and I start running. And I did it, and it's so nice. So I'm actually making a course about that app that I made.
我做过关于它的演讲。这是一个你可以制作的非常简单的应用，它展示了实时重载有多好。你正在调整 UI，它就在你的 iOS 模拟器中神奇地改变了。非常酷。所以，是的，我想这总结了这一切。所以圣诞快乐，宽扎节快乐，光明节快乐，
I've given a talk about it. It's a really simple app you can make, and it shows off how nice that live reloading is. You're tweaking the UI, and it just magically changes in your little iOS simulator. Very cool. So, yeah, I think that kind of wraps it up. So Merry Christmas, Happy Kwanzaa, Happy Hanukkah,
我可能错过的其他事情，你知道，因为这一集可能会在那个时候发布。祝你，你知道，节日快乐等等。感谢所有支持这个节目的听众。感谢 Eric 来到节目中并向我们解释 Clojure。我们非常感谢你的时间。你想给那个链接做个宣传，让人们获得那个折扣吗？是的，purelyfunctional.tv/throwdown。
other things I might have missed, you know, because this episode will probably go out, you know, around that time. Have, you know, happy holidays and all that. Thank you, everyone out there, for supporting the show. Thank you, Eric, for coming on the show and explaining Clojure to us. And we really appreciate your time. Do you want to give a shout-out to the link over time so people can get that discount? Yeah, purelyfunctional.tv slash throwdown.
酷。所以就是这样。而且，是的，玩得开心。祝编程愉快。希望你有一个很酷的圣诞项目。就像 Patrick 可能要构建的，你知道，正如我所说，某种机器人，它会，它会，你知道，恐吓他的邻居。我觉得你只是会让联邦调查局出现在我家门口。是的，我没有
Cool. So there it is. And yeah, and have fun. Happy hacking. Hopefully you have a cool Christmas project. Like Patrick's probably going to build, you know, like, you know, as I said, some robot that will, that will uh you know terrorize his neighborhood i feel like you're just gonna make the feds show up at my door yeah um i don't
真的有什么想法，但，噢，实际上我确实计划做很多绘图，我为一个游戏写了一个脚本，但这就像一个角色扮演游戏，像这些 RPG 游戏之一，有很多对话和角色，所以现在我实际上想去画那些角色。我想我可能会把它作为我的圣诞项目。但无论你的项目是什么，玩得开心，
really have anything in mind but uh oh actually i do plan on doing a lot of uh drawing um i wrote a script for um for a game but this is like a role-playing, like one of these RPG games where it's a lot about dialogue and characters, and so now I want to actually go and draw those characters. I think I'll probably make that my Christmas project. But whatever your project is, have fun,
祝圣诞快乐，我们明年见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，
and have a happy Christmas, and we'll see all you listeners next year. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。